when our firefighters arrived a number  of police officers and members of the  public were in the water trying to reach  and rescue the children  our crews entered the water  swam to the first child  and our specialist trained firefighters  including technical rescue  rescued three further children  the children were bought out of the  water where they received immediate life  support care from firefighters and our  ambulance colleagues  unfortunately the children in the water  were in cardiac arrest and were  receiving Advanced life support on route  to hospital  no matter how long they were in the  water for unfortunately not at the stage